Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys are the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah. Let's begin.
Okay. So we are covering Spider-Man, but.
Here's something that I want to throw out there real quick, right.
Because I know some people are going to ask the question, Rob,
didn't you cover this already? What I covered was Spider-Man too. Uh,
here's the important thing about this, right?
Spider-Man is probably one of the most important.
Spider-Man stories I'd say of the last 15 years. Okay.
The reason why is,
because this is the story where Peter Parker first met miles Morales. Right? So,
um, one of the things that we've talked about here over the course of,
of really some of the miles Morales videos that we've done,
and a lot of the Peter Parker videos that we did is we kind of talked about the
nature of the ultimate universe, right? So if you guys are familiar with this,
we just finished a video yesterday where we talked about that in the miles
Morales one. Right? So just kind of bear with me, right.
We'll probably have some new people to the channel.
I know you guys kind of like to get directly into it,
but bear with me for a second while I kind of, I kind of reiterate this, uh,
for, for the people who are new here, but who are new to Marvel comics, um,
and Marvel, you have a great, big, huge multi-verse right?
Technically the Marvel cinematic universe it's considered part of the
multi-verse that makes up all of Marvel comics. Uh,
we know that for a couple of different reasons. One,
because it actually has a numerical designation among the Marvel multi-verse and
two, because there's comics based on it. Right.
So that kind of brings it closer in line with being part of the Marvel
multi-verse, but where you had Marvel comics,
as it was originally launched in the 1960s, right.
With the fantastic four number one and so on and so forth,
that's referred to as earth six, one six, right.
Also known as the main Marvel universe. What we got in,
in the year 2000 was the creation of the ultimate universe.
And this was an answer to the question.
What would it look like if at that point in time in the year 2000 superheroes
had just basically popped up, right?
They just kind of emerged for the very first time. Uh, what would the,
what would those superheroes look like? How would they function? How it,
all that stuff worked. Ah,
and that's basically where you got Peter Parker in the ultimate universe.
Now ultimate Spider-Man was exceedingly popular, right?
It was hugely popular because in a lot of ways it was kind of an indirect
reboot, right?
Marvel didn't really reboot everything with the main Marvel universe Spider-Man
they just gave us a new one and people loved it. Right.
People absolutely loved it.
But what you saw was a story where basically Peter Parker died, right?
Peter Parker Spider-Man was killed and it might be who of us to go back and
cover that event. Right? Cover, uh, cataclysm and the death of, of Peter Parker.
Right. It might be who of us to do that? Just because, you know,
we're kind of doing a lot of this stuff because the new Spider-Man games coming
out for the PlayStation. Ah,
but the idea is that when that version of Peter Parker died, uh,
we ended up getting miles Morales and his place.
And when miles Morales first showed up, there was a lot of naysayers.
There were a lot of people who were just kind of like, Mozzerella sucks.
He's not really Spiderman. He's not really Peter Parker. That kind of a thing,
because it kind of came from a couple of different places.
A lot of fans were latched onto the idea of Peter Parker,
even when they were reading him before the ultimate universe was launched.
Right.
So all they really got was just another alternate reality version of Peter and
they loved it. A lot of people grew attached to Peter Parker.
Spider-Man in the ultimate universe when that was their first place to start in
Marvel comics,
but by whatever manner and whatever means a lot of people just didn't want.
To see things change. This story is.
In a lot of ways, kind of Brian, Michael snubbing,
people who were naysayers of miles, Morales, right. Uh,
people who were just like this,
this carrot is not going to last or anything like that.
It was kind of been just, just being like, no, he will, well,
he's going to be around for a long time.
And that's really where this comes from.
And I tell you that because it's important that you understand the historical
context of the story as we get into it.
So you can understand why the story is considered to be so important with all
that out of the way, just jumped to the main story itself. Uh,
and so what we ended up getting here is picking up in the main Marvel universe
or six one six with Peter, for Spider-Man and it's Peter Parker,
just kind of doing this stuff that Peter Parker does, right?
Like swinging around, coming across some criminals,
some guys who were doing some things they're not supposed to do.
But here's the funny thing about this because of the fact this story was written
as a way to kind of tie into,
or kind of bring together the ultimate universe and the main Marvel universe.
This story was written in such a way to where it was designed to treat people as
if they're aware of who Spider-Man is,
but they don't really know much about him. Right.
They don't really know a whole lot about the character, right?
So it was kind of reiterating the nature of Peter Parker.
And that's one of the things that you see in Marvel comics.
There are certain characters out there who people know who they are, right.
People know who iron man is. Now people know who Spider-Man is.
People know who Wolverine is, but knowing,
knowing who the character is and understanding the history and the context of
the character are two distinctly different. Thanks. You know,
so a lot of people know who iron man is,
but I doubt they really know anything about the Mandarin or I doubt they know
about stories like demon in a bottle and why it's so important. Uh, what is it,
the five nightmares run by Matt fraction, different things like that. Right?
Arno stark, Kieran Guillen's run a lot of people,
probably aren't really familiar with that.
So the idea is that we're just kind of given Peter Parker in terms of how Peter
Parker operates,
which just to say kind of amusing to himself about how much he loves New York
city and the fact that New York,
city's kind of like a thinking breathing entity, right?
That there are so many facets to this city.
You've got people who have their nose to the ground and they're just grinding
day in and day out just trying to make it by.
You've got people who are just super high up in their ivory, ivory towers,
you know,
the Tony Stark's the Reed Richards who don't really have to worry about small
time things. Right. But you can kind of have everybody who falls in between.
And there's just so many different varying types of people in the city of New
York that is just so unique in that way. It also has, uh, criminals,
there's criminals in New York city and Spiderman goes to visit some,
and he basically Wallops them one or two times shows him what for,
and then of course, pulling over the vehicle, you know,
which was their getaway car. And as soon as he's there,
he's met by the arrival of the cops, right. And the cops are just like,
take off your mask, shoulders, your face. You know, that, that kind of a thing.
Now the truth about this is I was never really part and parcel to this kind of
depiction of Spider-Man of Peter Parker.
And the reason why is because you have had stories over the years,
years where J Jonah Jameson and the daily bugle have kind of managed to sort of
turn, you know, the,
the idea of Spiderman into something where he can't really be trusted.
He's a minister, but the, the long and short of it is that over the year,
Spiderman was largely trusted by society. Right. You know,
your friendly neighborhood Spider-Man he was the good guy, right.
He was largely trusted in that way.
There have been times where it's waxed and waned, but in this,
since I kind of feel like it should have been one of those things where it's
like, thanks, Spiderman, you know, and then that's kind of it right now,
the fact that the cops show up here and he's behind the,
behind the wheel of a getaway car, might give him a little reason to be sus.
Right. But I'm a why I say that all the time, Mariah started saying,
so now I say it all the time. Right? Like suss, so weird word. But anyway, uh,
once he takes off and he kind of, you know, goes and does his thing,
he ends up finding this building, you know, this kind of a, this,
this office building basically where the, the, the river has been shattered,
right? The glass has been shattered. And he's kinda like,
that's a little weird now, of course,
he ends up being drawn to that location because of a giant, bright light,
almost kind of an explosion of sorts. And of course, once he gets there,
like the whole place kind of seems to be tarnished, right?
And there's just this white light or this,
this bright light emanating from it all now, as he gets in there.
And as he starts investigating his initial thought,
is this energy sources a little weird.
Now this story was released about a year after Spider-Man big time.
And for those of you guys who aren't really familiar,
if you ever wanted to get into Spiderman,
I always suggest people start with big time. We have that,
that whole series covered on my channel.
And big time was a sort of Dan slots run.
You had Spiderman and you had Mary Jane who were like married and all that kind
of stuff. And then you got one more day.
Then you got brand new day where Marvel basically nullified it all because that
was just so poorly received. Big time was kind of,
Marvel's huge shift with Peter Parker, right?
Focusing on like an all new age for Peter Parker Spider-Man,
but that's kind of the good place to start, right?
Because dance lot's run begins with that and runs all the way up through secret
Wars and after secret Wars into clone conspiracy. Right? So it's a,
it's like a 10, almost 15 year long run of Spider-Man. It's very,
very lengthy, but I think it's also incredibly good.
I think it's an amazing run on Spiderman,
but the whole idea behind this is that, uh, that,
that this takes place about a year after that. Now,
the reason why I mentioned that is because I'm not entirely parcel a partial to
how does this handle by Bendis right.
Bendis is notorious for running a character and then pretending like nothing
anybody did ever happen. Right.
And it's just like the only things that matter what this character is,
what I'm doing here and ignoring continuity in its entirety. Now,
whether it's kind of Venice is always that way. I'm not a hundred percent sure.
I wasn't really reading Bendis back when he was part of a,
of a vet publications with Jimmy Paul and the audio and joker Sadik,
I wasn't really reading him back then. I only really got familiar with Brian,
Michael Bendis once he actually came into main Marvel itself and was writing
like new Avengers, right. A new Avengers was a wholly new thing.
So he could kind of get away with that.
It's something that I think maybe a result of the, of his,
like his huge amount of popularity. And it's kinda like I'm Bendis,
I can do whatever the heck I want.
I don't know if that's really the case or not,
but the reason why that matters is because during Spider-Man big time,
Peter Parker's intelligence had always kind of been downplayed by Marvel comics,
right.
They never really kind of elevated Peter Parker to being on par with like Reed
Richards or Tony stark. You always kind of knew he was,
but they never really did any of that form. Instead,
what you ended up getting here is Peter Parker kind of looking at this and just
be like, man, this is weird. He's like, it's not,
it's not anything alien in nature. Uh,
maybe I should get ahold of like Tony stark or Reed Richards or something like
that. During big time.
One of the big things that Dan Slott did was focused on the intelligence of
Peter Parker and in being like Peter Parker is actually pretty,
dag-gone smart and he doesn't always need Reed Richards or Tony stark to solve a
problem on his own.
That was kind of solidified in a story where there was like a bomb that was
going to go off and nobody else could diffuse it.
And Peter Parker was the one who did right.
So it was kind of elevating his intelligence up and,
and basically telling the reader base, Hey, Peter,
Parker's not as dumb as he's being made out to be, you know, he's,
he's not just a Spider-Man right. He's a super intelligent guy.
Let's start treating him that way. So not entirely partial on how this works,
but as you start to navigating this room,
he starts to realize all this stuff belongs to Mysterio,
but all these things belong to him.
And that's when Mysterio tries to sneak up behind Peter and attack him.
And of course, Peter Parker, spider sense goes off any basically ends up,
you know, kind of,
kind of being aware that he's about to be attacked and manages to Dodge out of
the way now with Mysterio.
And one thing that a lot of you guys are probably aware of after having seen
Spider-Man far from home Mysterio is a legitimate,
credible threat to Peter Parker, right?
He's probably one of Peter Parker's most dangerous villains,
his ability to cast solutions to basically trick Peter Parker and his spider,
since it can be pretty difficult to overcome the stereo.
And that's one of the reasons why you have, you know,
Peter Parker kind of saying here,
like I've got to get this guy down as fast as I can because this guy is a real
and serious threat.
The other part of this is that Mysterio keeps rambling on about how like Peter
Parker's ruining things and he's kind of destroying things and so on and so
forth. And then he goes, as far as to say, like,
you have no idea what you're dealing with, right?
You have no idea what I'm capable of. Ah,
I missed out when you died the first time. I'm not going to miss out this time.
Right. So right off the bat,
our cue is that this is some kind of ability for Mysterio to actually look
through into the ultimate universe where that version of Peter Parker dive and
Mysterio wants to be in that universe or Peter Parker doesn't exist. Right?
His main nemesis, the person that always foiled his plans,
he just trying to find a way to escape. And so what you end up getting here is,
is Peter just kind of looking at this and saying like, like, what is this thing?
What is this some kind of a power generator or whatever this is,
it's weird that this is here,
but like I can call people that can basically break this down and take this
thing apart. So we don't really have to worry about it. Right? Well,
Peter Parker doesn't really know what's going on with this device.
He knows enough about mysterial to know it's probably not a good thing, right?
Like when supervillains start doing weird things that you don't understand,
you can usually just assume it's bad and you're not usually wrong in doing that
is a good rule of thumb to have. But of course in his desperation,
Mysterio ends up grabbing,
grabbing a handgun and firing it off and then missing Peter Parker and hitting
his device. And when that happens, he's yanked through, right.
Peter has seemingly yanked through, into basically the ultimate universe.
And this is the first time. One of the reasons why this is so big,
this is the very,
very first time in the history of Marvel comics that a character from the main
Marvel universe crossed over into the ultimate universe, right? This was a huge,
now the ultimate universe, it exists now in Marvel comics,
but it's nowhere near as big you'll as it was back in like the early to mid two
thousands, right around the time. And even really in the early 2000 tens,
when this story was written, ah,
this is when the ultimate universe was really kind of at its prime,
depending on, you know, what you were reading.
There was a lot of fall off after the death of Peter Parker. You know,
we can't really, you know, that's just an absolute thing.
We can't really argue that point,
but the death of Peter Parker and the ultimate universe actually made headlines,
tried to make national news headlines. And so because of that,
there was a lot of interest in the ultimate universe.
And so it was really a great time to capitalize on that, right.
To kind of give us this story, but this is a big deal when this first happened.
And so as Peter Parker's there, he's like, okay, this is weird.
Like it's suddenly daytime. Uh, I don't know what that great big,
huge building is over there. That's the true, Scalian that great, big,
huge tower looking thing off in the water. You guys probably recognize true.
Scalian from, uh, captain America, the winter soldier,
that's where this comes from.
That's why we say the Marvel cinematic universe is a combination of the ultimate
universe, the main Marvel universe in earth, 98,
where the heroes age in real time, uh,
it's kind of a combination of those three things,
but he has of traveling back to the building where, uh, where, where you had,
you know, the whole, um, immuno Mysterio,
his base of operations and everything popping off. And, uh,
and he basically ends up breaking into the place only to find out that it's
occupied with some girl in a towel. And he's like my bed,
it basically bails out right. Ends up taking off from there.
He actually ends up rescuing a guy who's, you know, kind of being, uh,
being beat up a little bit.
He takes out the two of the two people who were beating this dude up.
And he basically says, we're just playing pool.
And then suddenly they jumped him.
But the fact that he's wearing a Peter parser,
a Peter Parker costume wearing a Spiderman costume does not go unnoticed by the
sky. And he's like, look, I appreciate you saving me, but like,
it's really in bad taste for you to wear that costume right now.
What's more so than that. He's like, you know, we all need heroes,
but that was Peter Parker's costume.
And that's one of the big things to know when Peter Parker died and, and,
and even Peter Parker is Spiderman. His identity was known like when,
when all that popped off, his identity was known to the world. People were like,
the world needs to know that this is the kid who,
who tried to save everybody who died a hero.
That's why the death of Peter Parker was so massive in the ultimate universe,
right? Like, imagine, for example,
that like in the main Marvel universe and Marvel comics did Ironman dies and
it's this great big,
huge event that crosses over every single comic that they have. Right.
It's like the death of Ironman, you know,
the incredible Hulk and the captain America tie in and all that kind of stuff,
right?
Like everything ties into just the fact that iron man died and how everybody's
coping with it. That's what the death of Peter Parker was. It was just huge.
It was massive because Spider-Man had never actually been killed off in Marvel
comics with no intention of bringing him back. Right.
That's just never happened before. Right. I mean,
I kind of tried it with the clone saga,
but that was never going to happen with the ultimate universe.
It's the way it is. Peter Parker has been dead, you know,
he's like the Peter Parker Spider-Man concept is dead and miles Morales had
taken it over and has been that way ever since. So it was kind of a big deal.
It was a huge deal when it happened.
But this guy that the fact that this guy reveals that they know who Peter Parker
is really throws like the main Marvel universe, Peter Parker off,
because his identity is something that he keeps insanely close guarded right now
in the, in, in civil war.
He revealed it to the world just as kind of a proof of the,
that he trusted Ironman superhero registration. But of course,
as we saw in the aftermath of that brand new day,
that Dr. Strange came along and just magic everybody's memory of,
of Peter Parker's identity out of their heads. Right. He's just like magic.
And then nobody remembered that Peter Parker was Spider-Man and that was
essentially it. Right? That was, that was basically it.
That's probably what they're going to end up doing in Spiderman. But the,
the whole point behind this is that this throws Peter Parker for a loop,
because he's kind of like, okay, that's crazy. Like wherever it is,
they're referring to me in the third person. So one,
this guy doesn't know who I am, but he knows who Peter Parker is.
So that means there was a Peter Parker here in this place,
what in the world is going on right now?
And so what is happening is he's ultimately met by the, we are rival of miles,
Morales and miles Morales pops up. And he's just like, no way, right?
Because to the eyes of miles Morales,
this is the ultimate universe version of Peter Parker. It's like,
Peter Parker has come back. That's what kind of blew things off. Right?
That's what drives that. That's what makes miles Morales kind of go nuts here.
But with that being said, guys, we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob court. You guys enjoyed this video.
Make sure you drop a light. Now we'll catch you all later.
Bruce.
[inaudible].